as we stay with our top story the ground
war in Gaza has begun and this brings us
to a very very important question
whether or not Israel is forced to open
a two-front war what role should the US
play how do we protect our American
soldiers in the region and deter any
threat from Iran without sparking a
world war or an entire breakout of war
in the entire region uh joining us uh
once again his former Secretary of State
our friend Mike Pompeo is back Mr
secretary to follow up a little bit on
on a very good analysis by both Colonel
North and you and Aaron who we just
heard from so with this ground War
beginning certainly the net result that
Israel is going to need out of this is
that neither Gaza nor Lebanon can remain
launching pads for Rockets being fired
into Israel the second very important
goal has to be the tunnels which we
spoke of earlier the the network of
tunnels so I I want to walk through this
if I can with you front by front so the
first front first battle is going to be
Gaza that ground war has begun now we
would expect that Hezbollah is going to
ratchet up their rocket attacks from the
north now we have a two-front war then
you have the threat of Syria we have
talked about the threat of the houti
rebels from from Yemen and then the
Iranians themselves and what the
strategy has to be to cut off the the
head of the snake but if it's a onef
front War I think they handle it I think
they can handle the two-front war where
do you see the most trouble and the
greatest danger for Israel right now and
how would you go about
it well Sean I I agree the the more
fronts the more complexity uh we should
also remember that there are diplomatic
and political fronts as well that
they'll being confronting uh just today
at the United Nations only 17 countries
voted against a demanding a complete
compl ceasefire of the victim and so
they've got a very complex information
campaign that they are fighting as well
and now they're going to be fighting the
Biden Administration that has demanded a
humanitarian pause we all know that's
silly right $100 million going there is
going to be $100 million worth of more
fuel $100 million worth of tunnel
reinforcements $100 million more
Munitions that's what the Hamas
terrorists will actually use that money
for so they've got uh they've got that
information Warfare front as well the
United States can play the Cent role at
preventing these other fronts from
opening so I think you may have even
neglected another front Judean Samaria
the West Bank America can have a role in
keeping containment uh in the West Bank
it can certainly do good work making
clear to the regime in Iran that
there'll be real cost and posts on them
Colonel North did a fine job of talking
about some of them for example today
Sean today four million barrels of crude
o were sold by the Iranians just as we
sat here today while they're holding
Americans hostage and their foreign
minister was in New York we can do
simple things uh things that are
non-kinetic that can impose real cost on
the Iranian leadership convincing them
that they need to restrain these proxy
forces a second when they come after
Americans you can't just fire back at
Munitions when they when they attack
American soldiers and we fire at
ammunition Depots that basically that
validates that that seconds the Iranian
understanding of the weakness that the
Iranian leadership saw in Afghanistan
that they have seen when the Chinese spy
balloon flow over our country we have to
get America back on its front foot in a
way that actually will that will
convince the Iranians that opening up
these other fronts would be a detriment
to them not to their proxies not to the
folks in Iraq or in Yemen but to them if
we get that right Sean we can deter more
fronts than the Israelis can handle and
then we just need to give the Israelis
all the space to make decisions for
themselves to do the necessary which is
to ensure that something like what
happened on October 7th never is
possible of happening again to them no I
can't say any better it is sad to see um
you know the fact that all of this money
International Aid money American
taxpayer dollars have been spent to help
build infrastructure schools hospitals
and all of that money wasted on a
network of tunnels and a terror Network
for one purpose and that is the stated
goal in hamasa Charter which is the
elimination of of Israel with the help
support the scheming military plotting
planning of Iran specifically what
should the world's reaction to Iran be
you let me go back as Secretary of State
during the Trump Administration you guys
accomplished something I never saw
thought I'd see in my lifetime you
created an alliance between the United
States and Israel and Egypt and Jordan
and Saudi Arabia and the Emirates and
you stood together we had intelligence
sharing at levels we' never had before
mostly private relationship but I was
very aware of it uh when I'd interview
you you'd give me a little smile um
which kind of let me know that I was on
the right path and I was trying to put
pieces from sources together um but your
CIA Roots were held very strong you
never gave me a real clue um but I know
we had this can you talk about that
Alliance can we re can we achieve that
Alliance again and and it was really to
stand against Iranian hegemony in the
region and and them ever getting a
nuclear weapon um could we get back to
that oh Shan we certainly can uh but it
takes American leadership uh You're
right our our our theory of the case was
this we wanted good things for the
Palestinians um but we knew in order to
get that appeasing Iran wasn't the
direction for that in the same way
demanding that Israel stand down is not
good for the people who are living in
Gaza either uh we understood that Iran
was a threat not only to Israel the
little sat and to the United States the
great Satan but a threat to people
living in the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
people living in Bahrain people living
in the Emirates and we isolated Iran we
had we literally for the first time had
Iran on an island stuck trying to figure
out how it is they're going to get back
from the pressure that had been put on
them economic pressure diplomatic
pressure uh and when they began to act
out Military pressure Sean remember too
um we were very clear about our support
for Israel not only did we move the
embassy from t be to Jerusalem but we
declared the Golan Heights the rightful
property of the Jewish people their
rightful Homeland those were things that
that so much in the establishment
foreign policy that those will create
World War III well we can see you you
create risk of that very kind of
regional or even potentially Global
configration when you're weak when you
invite the Iranians to do precisely what
they did by unleashing Hamas on 1300
civilians in the southern part of Israel
we have to understand and and both of
your stories tonight Sean make clear I
think to all of us here in America evil
still roams the Earth and there is a
responsibility to ensure that when it
happens when that evil exposes itself
that we do everything we can to prevent
it from impacting those who are good
human beings trying to do the right
thing we know who the victim is here we
know who the aggressor is here and
America simply needs to stand on the
side of those people who are fighting
for basic human decency I wish you could
bring that message to every college and
university across the country um that
has taken positions that frankly are
incomprehensible to me um thank you Mr
secretary I know we we kept you up a lot
late tonight we appreciate all your
support hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else